>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Mohamed Sheriff: So,
good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you all for coming.
A special thanks to the Library of
Congress and The National Endowment
for the Arts for giving us this
opportunity to meet together
for those of our peeps
in the back there.
My name is Mohamed Sheriff.
I'm a literature specialist at The
National Endowment for the Arts,
where I manage the translation and
Creative Writing Fellowship program.
And I have the distinct
honor and pleasure
of welcoming today these
two phenomenal authors,
Peter Ho Davies and Lisa Ko.
If you guys are not familiar
with who these authors are,
Peter Ho Davies, a two-time
NEA Creative Writer fellow.
Wrote the short-story
collections "Equal Love"
and "The Ugliest House
in the World."
His novel, "The Welsh Girl" is
set near a prisoner of war camp
in North Wales after
D-Day, was long-listed
for the Man Booker of Prize.
"The Fortunes" this lovely thing
right here, his most recent novel
and the one we'll be
discussing today,
follows four Chinese-American
characters
from the 1860s to the present.
Peter is joining us from
Ann Arbor, Michigan.
Lisa Ko is the author of her
debut novel, "The Leavers."
Which won the 2016 PEN Bellwether
Prize for socially engaged fiction.
The novel tells the story of Deming
Guo, who was abandoned in the Bronx
by his undocumented Chinese mother.
And is raised by a
white couple upstate.
Lisa joins us today
from Brooklyn, New York.
[ Applause ]
All right, we have a
few housekeeping rules.
Just for the Library of Congress
and respect of these authors,
please silent your phones.
We're going to take
questions at the end.
Maybe the last 15 minutes or so.
But just remember,
this is being recorded.
So, if you come up to the
mic, you have now agreed
to be recorded and
publicized, I guess.
So, let's get started.
Lisa.
>> Lisa Ko: Yes.
>> Mohamed Sheriff: Peter, welcome.
Thank you, guys for joining us.
Is this your first time in D.C?
First book festival?
>> Lisa Ko: This is my first
national book festival.
>> Mohamed Sheriff: And
how's it been so far?
>> Lisa Ko: It's been pretty rainy.
[ Laughs ]
>> Mohamed Sheriff: Yes.
It is. Pretty terrible
day to come out.
>> Peter Ho Davies: And
I'm mostly feeling .
. . I like the emphasis on national.
We talked a lot about the American
story in the last day or so.
But as a Brit, I'm feeling slightly
embarrassed [inaudible] to be here.
>> Mohamed Sheriff: Yes.
So, I guess so that the
audience has a sense
of where you guys are
in your career.
Before we get to the book, you
guys can take us to where you are
and how you got to these books.
Lisa, this is your first novel.
And you came out of the
gate just grabbing hearts
and dragging it across the page.
And Peter, this is your fourth book.
Maybe you guys can talk a little bit
about your process and how you came
to your writing career and
how you got to these books.
And the importance of them
right now in your career.
Little stuff.
>> Peter Ho Davies: Yes.
Well, what I'm admiring Lisa
for is writing a first
book that is a first novel.
Because it took me several
efforts to get to that point.
I had to write a couple of
short-story collections.
And I love that form.
But I know that I struggled
mightily transitioning
from being a short-story
writer to being a novelist.
I used to joke that my first
novel, "The Welsh Girl"
which is this World War II novel
took me seven years to write.
Which is longer than the
second World War lasted.
It's a little embarrassing.
And with the fortunes.
And I thought the second novel
might be a little easier.
But "The Fortunes" also took
me seven or eight years.
And the joke for that
one, is that it's partly
about the Chinese building
the transcontinental railroad.
And it took me longer
to write the book
than it took them to
build the railroad.
There were more Chinese on the
railroad, it should be said.
It took me so long to write it,
that that joke is now
in the back of the book.
But I think for me, that
movement from one form
to the other was a struggle.
I still am drawn to both forms.
And in some ways, I suppose
the four-part structure
of "The Fortunes" is
a kind of hybrid form,
somewhere between a novel
and short-story collection.
And while I'm sure that's
somewhat to do with my limitations
as a writer or the
fact that my center
of gravity is still
slightly with the short form.
I guess I like to retrospectively
claim that hybrid forms speak
to the hybrid identities
of the characters.
Because the nice version
of that, right?
A nice idea.
It wasn't exactly in my mind as
I was writing it, I have to say.
>> Mohamed Sheriff: Right.
Awesome. Lisa?
>> Lisa Ko: To be fair, "The
Fortunes" does span like 200 years.
So, you could have spent
10 to 12 years writing it.
>> Peter Ho Davies: That's true.
Yes. [Laughs] I like that.
It's quicker than yes.
That's good.
>> Lisa Ko: It's also
funny that you mentioned
that the you thought the
second novel would be easier.
But it actually wasn't.
Which is kind of depressing
to hear about now.
As I'm starting to think
about the second novel.
And . . .
>> Peter Ho Davies: The
one thing that was good
about the second novel is
that I knew that at points
in writing the first novel,
I had thought I will
never finish this book.
And so when I arrived at that point,
writing the second novel, I thought,
well, you can never know you're
never going to finish it.
>> Lisa Ko: Right.
At least one was possible.
>> Peter Ho Davies: That's right.
>> Lisa Ko: You got there once.
And I try to keep that in mind,
too, as I'm kind of returning
to the writing process, again.
But it is really interesting
because it's like, you know,
while it took me seven years to
write and publish "The Leavers"
and I was working on short
stories at the time, too.
Unlike, Peter, I never actually
finished a short-story collection.
But I often cheated on the
novel with short stories
and published them here and there.
But it's also been
fascinating to think about how,
even after publication and the
success that comes with publication
and marketing the book, at the
end of the day, you still have
to sit down and keep writing.
And you're kind of just
left with yourself again.
And so, working with
the second book,
I'm like, well here we are again.
Like, back to kind of
starting from scratch.
Back to facing my own limitations
and kind of like dealing
with the blank screen or blank page.
>> Mohamed Sheriff: I think that's
important for us to sort of talk
about the structure and the process.
Because you both ended up writing in
these four parts, four -part novels.
And I'm wondering how much
research went into this period book.
Because it so much
heavy with research,
it almost reads like
historical fiction.
I mean, it is historical
fiction in many parts.
And Lisa, the motivation
for your book, I'm sure,
had to do a significant
amount of research as well.
So, you guys let's talk about that,
what went into actually
building this.
>> Peter Ho Davies: In my case,
a lot of it is book research.
The first part of the book
takes places in the 1860s.
The second part is the 1920s and 30s
about the Chinese-American
movie star Anna May Wong.
And the third section is set
in the 1980s during the period
when Vincent Chin was a
hate-crime victim in Detroit.
And it oddly, each of those
represent a certain different
research challenges.
There is a fair amount of material
about the building of the railroad,
the transcontinental in the 1860s.
But less about the life of
the Chinese who built it.
It's not an accident, of course.
Their lives are less
documented, less well known.
So, there were lots of
gaps to sort of fill,
imaginatively in various ways.
With Ann May Wong,
on the other hand,
she was a global celebrity
in her day.
So, there was almost
too much material.
For a while I worried that there was
so much factual material out there,
that I wasn't sure where the
fictional space was to invent.
And I only really was released from
that anxiety when I figured in a way
that she's like any
global celebrity today.
She's like Angelina Jolie today.
What she might say in a public
interview might not actually be the
absolute truth.
So, there's a public image and
a private life beneath that.
That the fiction can probe a
little bit that's not as accessible
to the historical record
in some ways.
And with Vincent's story, it's
a lot more recent allowing
newspaper research.
I got to visit some of
the sites of the attack
because I live near
Detroit, as well.
So, it was mixture of various
books, newspaper accounts
and some site visits, as well.
And I did actually go, I should
say, to travel the railroad
across the Sierra Nevada's
where the Chinese did a lot
of work on the railroad.
Of course, it's slightly
different route now.
And I'm still doing it more
than a 100 years later.
But there's still some sense of the
landscape, the color of the sky,
the temperature, some of the
flora and fauna being common.
So, while I can't go back in time,
there is real pleasure in being able
to go to those locations.
>> Mohamed Sheriff: Absolutely.
Lisa.
>> Lisa Ko: I also, like you
Peter, I took the real-life stories
as the initial starting
point of the book.
But kind of felt like I needed to
sort of push beyond that in order
to let the story open up.
So, "The Leavers" was initially
inspired by these stories
that I was reading in the news
about undocumented mothers
who had their U.S. born
children, who are citizens,
taken away from them and
adopted by American families.
While the mothers were
being deported or detained.
So, I was really just
kind of horrified
and interested by these stories.
And sort of what they said about
us as Americans and about identity
and family and class and race.
But I definitely felt intimidated
by the subject material at first.
You know, I'm not an adoptee, I'm
not a parent, I'm not from China.
So, I did a lot of research.
There were several years that I kind
of allowed research to, you know,
let me procrastinate writing.
I traveled to China.
Found where my characters were from.
Read a lot.
Spoke to a lot of people.
And then sort of had to figure out
how to separate that from the story
and let the characters
do their thing.
Beyond trying to prove to
myself that I did the research.
>> Peter Ho Davies:
Well, that's fascinating.
Because the research question
can be about historical material
but it can also be about, I
think, for both us that feeling
of cultural research
in a certain sense.
That while we have Chinese roots.
It's still this feeling of I still
need to, being of mixed race,
I felt like I had to go learn
about that culture and go
to some of those places as well.
And so that's almost an internal
research in a certain sense.
>> Lisa Ko: Absolutely.
>> Peter Ho Davies: To make yourself
feel that you have the right
to write about the material.
>> Lisa Ko: Yes.
That's a great way to say it.
I think internal research
is a huge part of writing
that we never really talk about.
Which it's almost, to me, feels
like the bulk of the work sometimes.
It's very psychological.
>> Mohamed Sheriff: Lisa,
you mentioned something
about the characters and
feeling them authentic.
Right? So, two characters that you
guys sort of created in this world
where women as the
minority is Polly, Anna May.
And they sort of stick out in my
mind because they're dreamers.
They're strivers.
There is so much pulling at
them, pulling down on them.
Yet, they persevere.
And you guys both created
those characters.
Right? And I was going to
say that the other women are
on the periphery but
they're really not.
They encounter them all the time.
Anna May even has prostitutes
taking her name.
So, to the extent to where
they're so intermingled.
But can you guys sort of
talk about your relationship
to those characters and why it
was important for them, for women,
to be represented and to be
that sort of juxtaposition
between the timid Asian
or the prostitute
and all the different things
and how you both sort of came
to have these upstanding characters?
>> Lisa Ko: I mean Polly was
sort of initially inspired,
again, by these news stories.
But it was mostly the frame work
were the facts surrounding her.
I knew that she was
undocumented immigrant
from a certain part of China.
That she was a mother.
And that she and her son
had gotten separated.
And that she was living in New
York and she would get deported.
So, I was trying to figure out
what to write around those facts.
What would a person have to be
like and want in order to kind
of risk their life
migrating to another country
as an undocumented migrant.
Having to take the risks of paying
$50,000 to come to New York.
What would it take for this
character to have to survive working
in New York paying this debt
back, raising her child.
Right? So, I think all of
these things kind of fed
into her character in terms
of making her strong willed,
very independent minded, kind
of having that adventure spirit.
And it sort of became
kind of her storyline.
Like she's, throughout the book
she's kind of constantly looking
for a way to kind of figure out how
to live beyond all
these expectations
that people are putting on her.
So, she's, as a woman anywhere,
she's encountering
sexism and the patriarchy.
And she's kind of figuring
out how to be a mother,
how to be a woman on her own terms.
>> Peter Ho Davies: Yes.
I think for me, you know,
I stumbled a little bit
on to Anna May's narrative as I was
in the midst of writing the book.
The first part drew me
to the transcontinental.
I was actually interested in the
idea, at least, that an early wave
of Chinese immigration into the U.S.
was something of a bachelor society.
It was a lot of male labor for the
railroads to work in the gold mines.
And there's mentally had very
difficult and challenging lives,
which is what the first part of
the book addresses to some degree.
But in the research, it became
very clear that the lives
of the smaller number
of Chinese women,
I think there was one Chinese woman
for every 20 men who
came in that period.
But those lives were, because many
of them worked as prostitutes,
were in many ways much,
much harsher.
Much more desperate than men who
were working on the railroad.
And so I felt like it was
incumbent upon me to sort
of address their lives a little bit.
Began to think about
that space in many ways.
And I think my interest in Anna May
comes a little bit out of that sense
that for all that some
of the male figures
in the Chinese-American history
have had a very difficult time.
The women have almost
consistently had a difficult
and challenging time in some ways.
And I think in the context
of the narrative they
represent the strongest figures
in the book to my way of thinking.
Because they're the
survivors, I think in many ways.
And I think for me that felt very
important in the context of learning
about Chinese-American history
and to some degree
about Chinese culture.
Because certainly from the period,
at least where the book starts,
the valuation in Chinese culture
of men and women, boys and girls,
is so distinctly unequal
in various ways.
It felt as though I wanted to think
about that question and address it.
And I was very conscious even from
the get-go that we move from a space
where we think in the
1860s of a largely male,
bachelor society, Chinese rivals.
And we think in a more
recent context of a lot
of adopted baby girls
arriving from Chine as well.
So, it felt interesting to think
about those two gendered groups
of immigrants at different ends
of the historical spectrum.
>> Mohamed Sheriff: Absolutely.
I would like to go back
to the male component.
And sort of do this again.
I'm thinking of Ling and John.
Who, interestingly struggle with
attractiveness and, you know,
actually being able to sleep
with these prostitutes.
Which [inaudible] because they
won't sleep with Chinese men.
And John being the sort of,
you know, and he's searching
for his identity as well.
And his attractiveness
and how he appeals.
And then there is this overarching
patriarchy that's happening.
Lisa, you sort of .
. . you have that in every aspect
of how Polly relates to her father,
to Leon, to all these different men.
There is this don't do this
because you're a woman.
You're unappealing.
Never work out for you.
You know, all these
different things.
So, can you guys talk
about the male characters
and something like their struggles.
>> Lisa Ko: Let me think about.
[Laughs]
>> Peter Ho Davies: As the
designated male, Chinese male.
I think Anna May Wong character
made me think quite a lot
about this question.
She's globally famous
for being Chinese.
And famous for playing
exotic characters.
The Madame Butterfly characters,
the Dragon Lady characters,
all the stereotypes we think of now.
And she's one of the agents
of creating those stereotypes
in some way.
She becomes successful and
famous for portraying those.
And while she's famous in
the west for those roles,
she's also somewhat reviled in China
for undertaking those
roles, I think.
But I do think there is a kind
of Western exoticization
classic instance of Orientalism,
in which Asian women, Chinese women
are sexualizing some of these ways.
And Anna May seems like she was a
very specific early example of that.
Although there are
precursors as well.
And the sexual visibility in
those ways of Chinese women,
those stereotypes, also
creates other stereotypes
that were banned upon the males.
Right? So, the women are,
if they're Dragon Ladies,
then the men by comparison,
the Chinese men
by comparison can seem
effeminate, I think.
And so this goes partly to the
way those images are constructed.
But it also goes back even to the
earliest periods of the Gold Rush
and the transcontinental.
The Chinese men arrive.
They're wearing cues, which
to Westerners look like a kind
of female kind of way
of wearing the hair.
They are thought to
be smaller and weaker.
And that's one of the
things that they're work
on the transcontinental
sort of pushes back upon
as a stereotype in various ways.
So, there are a number of factors
that'll play into that space.
But it does feel like sort of
ironic, sort of tragic tandem
that both male and female
identities, at least sexually,
are exaggerated in
opposite directions.
And it does feel as
though there is a kind
of binary at work in this regard.
>> Mohamed Sheriff: And Lisa, Leon
is sort of contradictory to that.
Because he's in a loving
relationship with Polly.
And he's sort of a
strong, brut of a man.
He's the complete opposite of that.
>> Lisa Ko: Yes.
He's definitely .
. . I mean he's Polly's boyfriend.
He's a meat cutter.
He's kind of this beefy muscular
dude who is kind of like silent
and macho in a lot of ways.
I mean, we're all products
of the world we live in.
Right? And Daniel .
. . or Deming, he kind of goes by
both names throughout the book.
Who is my protagonist is also a
male, Chinese-American character
who has sort of an
interesting, plays character-wise,
as a male adoptee of
two white parents.
In contrast, his foil is
sort of this female adoptee,
his friend Angel, who
is a Chinese adoptee.
And sort of fetish .
. . She's kind of fetishized in her
own ways by her adoptive parents.
And that's something
that I think I saw
in "The Fortune" that
I really enjoyed.
That was kind of like this role
that we put on Chinese girls.
Like what does it mean in terms of
kind of fetishizing girls over boys.
What does that say about
the expectations that we put
on Chinese-American girls
over Chinese-American boys.
>> Peter Ho Davies: I think it's one
of those ironies, if we come from,
at least historically
a cultural space
in which boys are valued over girls.
One of the odd narratives of the
Chinese-American experience is
that in these context, sometimes
girls are valued over boys.
So, the movement from China to
the U.S. in some ways invert some
of those gender valuations.
I think in some ways, too.
It's ironic and it doesn't serve
either gender particularly well.
But the flip seems
interesting to me.
And it seems like a potential way,
a little mode of conflict
to address in the book.
>> Mohamed Sheriff: So, I
think we would sort of be .
. . if we didn't go into subject
of identity and you guys have sort
of touched on it a little bit
as you're explaining things.
Something that struck in a
heavy way as reading this.
And I thought you guys
handled it so well.
And it was beautiful.
Is this loss of identity and
this gaining of a new identity
to sort of lose identity again.
Or be lost within that
weird middle place.
So, I'm thinking Deming
becomes Daniel.
Palon [assumed spelling]
becomes Polly,
losing the cues, dressing
more western.
You guys do these symbolic
things that signify a loss
of identity, a loss of self.
And then this real self, you guys
have this interesting you guys move
to in different ways.
Where the real self gets buried down
and the character is
almost revisited
as a way of touching themselves.
And realizing that there is loss
and can measure how lost they
are from their real selves.
So, can you guys talk
about this identity theme
and how it's playing
an importance of that.
And then we'll get
to this middle space
of being hyphenated
American whatever it,
nationality American thing.
Because I think it leads to that.
>> Lisa Ko: Yes.
That was something that I felt
like something I wanted
to explore in my book.
And that I also really enjoyed
in "The Fortunes" was this
Asian-American double consciousness.
Where the characters in both our
books, I think, are being seen
by other people in certain ways.
That are at odds with
how they see themselves.
But yet, how they're being seen
effects how they see themselves.
Right. So, there's this kind
of constant back and forth.
And I really also wanted to resist
having it be this simplistic either
or between western and
eastern, or American or China.
Because I think that also
negates the Asian-American
or the Chinese-American experience,
which is really important.
And at the center to my character
as them trying to find a way
to forge their own identities,
outside of their families,
outside of whatever other
social pressures there are.
>> Peter Ho Davies: And it's
interesting, too, because for both
of us the attention to
names, western names,
Chinese names play an
awful lot of part in it.
And speech is sort of
doubling of the identity
that we've been talking about.
But yes, it does always feel
to me, and even when we talk
about Chinese-Americanness, it feels
as though that hyphenated identity.
And I think this is true for a
number of hyphenated identities.
Seems to imply a kind of choice.
Which side of the hyphen to lead?
Where do your loyalties lie?
And that feels always like
a no-win choice to me.
If one cleaves too much to one's
heritage, then there is a, what,
failure to assimilate
into the mainstream
of the country that
one is living in?
If one assimilates too
much is that a betrayal
of the heritage that one comes from?
So, when we think of it as a choice,
as a duality, it feels very much
as though it's just lose-lose.
And I think that's
at the heart of some
of the anxieties of inauthenticity.
People in this culture
can experience.
But I think the idea, and Lisa's
talked about this very too,
that the hybrid identity is
its own identity in some sense.
This is one of the
reasons that I chose the
"The Fortunes" as a title in end.
Because the fortune cookie, while
we know it not to be Chinese,
but we don't go to
Chinese restaurants
and have fortune cookies.
Where, of course, the food is
also not called Chinese food.
It's just food.
>> Lisa Ko: Right, it
came from California.
>> Peter Ho Davies: Yes.
Right? But it somehow also
feels like a very specific
and somewhat humble Chinese-American
signifier in some ways, as well.
It's not of one culture
or the other.
But it's somewhere in
that middle ground.
I wouldn't suggest there
was authenticity even
in the hybrid identity.
>> Lisa Ko: Right.
I agree that it's like .
. . it is hybrid to
think of its itself.
Whereas if we're saying, we're
choosing between Chinese-American,
it's almost saying that
I'm not an American.
You know. Like, American
culture doesn't look like me.
And I think that's
completely incorrect.
>> Peter Ho Davies: Well, I
think for me that it was .
. .I mean I grew up in Britain.
And certainly, when I was
younger I was very conscious
of not looking British.
Britain has become
separate to Brexit,
and much more multicultural
community in the time
that I've lived, I've
been away from it.
But my face did not
look particular English
as I defined Britishness
when I was growing up.
And so, I always had this idea
that if I went other places.
If I went to China, or if I
went to Singapore or Malaysia,
where my mother's from, that I would
potentially belong in those spaces.
But even that feels .
. . I can remember living in
Singapore for a little while.
And enjoying the anonymity
of walking down the street
and looking like everybody else.
>> Lisa Ko: Until you
open your mouth.
>> Peter Ho Davies: Until
you open your mouth.
Right. [Laughs] In fact, once
I remember getting into a cab
in Singapore and I
hadn't said very much.
I don't think the accent had given
me away as yet to the cab driver.
But he said to me,
you're not from here.
And said, well, okay.
How can you tell?
He said, you're too short.
And that was really interesting.
Because I was shocked by that.
Because I'd internalized stereotypes
that all Chinese people are short.
He was like, no, obviously
not in Singapore.
Many are much taller than me.
So, it was just a reminder
in a sense not fitting
in there made me feel like I don't
fit in either of these places.
So, maybe we have to find some
combination of those identities
that is my own in some
ways so that I can fit in.
>> Mohamed Sheriff: Lisa,
can you also speak to that?
Because I feel like no one
embodies that more than Deming.
Because he wants his name
stripped away from him.
He's still harking back.
And he wants this ideal world.
That he fits in.
That he can speak Cantonese
with others.
Sort of has this secret
language with other people
who speak Cantonese
in that restaurant.
And then he becomes Americanized.
And then goes over to China.
And feels alienated there, too.
So, can you speak to that?
>> Lisa Ko: Absolutely.
Yes. that was definitely
something that I wanted to examine
with Deming's journey
throughout the book.
Where it's kind of
like he's being brought
to this new town by
his adoptive parents.
They change his name.
They want him to assimilate
in a certain way.
And it's not the right
choice for him.
It's not really taking his
own needs into account.
And, as you said, he goes to China.
And he's like, well, I
was born in New York.
I'm not really part of here, either.
So, it's kind of, his journey is
really trying to find his own way.
That he eventually finds with other
Chinese-Americans in New York City.
So, it's kind of saying, again, like
that's the place where we can belong
and not really have to ascribe to
either of those kind of simplistic,
white-middle class
America versus China.
There is a very vast space
in between those two.
>> Peter Ho Davies: I love
that section in the book
with Deming back in China.
But I also found myself envying
him because he speaks Chinese.
His Chinese rusty but he gets
better the longer he spends there.
And so he begins to be able to
navigate that space much better.
And I don't speak any Cantonese,
as my mother's language.
I don't speak any Cantonese.
But it speaks to not just the
way look but the way we sound.
The language we have access to also
shapes identity for us as well.
So, I had felt both a kinship
with his experience of feeling not
at home in the place that he
might have thought was home.
But I also envied his
ability to adapt to that home.
Better than I could.
>> Lisa Ko: Yes.
I think he has much more of agility
of like code-switching,
than I do too.
Because I can't speak
fluently either.
>> Mohamed Sheriff: So, there is
this one thing that I really wanted
to talk about with you two.
Something that I noticed throughout.
So, the white characters.
So, I'm thinking Peter, Kay,
Elaine, Jim, Mr. Crocker.
They all have this eye
of invisibility, right?
Where regardless of what happens
and amount of experiences they have
with certain immigrants, they never
fully see them or enter that space
where they begin to see
them where they are.
Right? Even to the point
where Deming is in China,
and they're Skyping on his birthday.
And his Mom yells out,
his name is Deming.
Not Daniel.
Right? And it's just like
they still don't get it.
It goes over their head.
Why the choice to leave
them in that sort
of ignorant space, or blind space?
>> Peter Ho Davies:
That's a good question.
I'm looking at Lisa.
>> Lisa Ko: I mean, yes.
Kaya and Peter [assumed spellings]
are Daniel's adoptive parents.
And I really saw them
very much as a product
of their socioeconomic class.
Their upper middleclass academics.
Their sort of liberal,
well-meaning, white people.
They're like a lot of people
that I've met in my life.
And to them, it's sort of like
their journey is really part
of his journey as well.
So, him coming to his own, finding
his own home, his own family kind
of means that he has to reject
both his adoptive family
and his birth family
to find his own family.
So, story-wise, that's kind
of why they end where .
. . the story where they are.
And where he is.
>> Peter Ho Davies: It seems
as if they are, you know,
and I think about some of the
figures in "The Fortunes" now
that you mention Charles
Crocker the railroad magnet
who employs my character Ling.
And while that's not an
obviously a parental relationship,
it's kind of quasi parental.
Ling is Eurasian.
He sort of looks at Crocker as
a father figure in certain ways.
But, in a way, there's a kind of
individuation question going on.
There's that feeling of the
parents, or the parental figure,
sees the character in a certain way.
Into kind of a white gaze,
I suppose in those regards.
And for the character to be able to
understand himself or see himself,
he has to sort of step
away from that, I suppose.
So, it almost feels as
though the, in a sense,
ultimately the white
characters do, I think,
fail to see what the
Chinese characters
or the Chinese-American characters.
But maybe that's the point.
Because the Chinese-American
characters have to figure
out who they are separate
to the gaze from outside.
And again, we go back to that
tension we talked about earlier
between our identities being
built in some kind of negotiation
between how we're seen and how
we see ourselves internally.
Right? And how do those line up?
And which do we lean into more
or less at different times?
>> Lisa Ko: Right.
>> Mohamed Sheriff: So, just
sort of open it up a little bit.
So, I read this, both these
books as a Liberian-American.
Right? And found myself
in a lot of these pages.
And I'm thinking about
the section with Vincent
where Vincent gets murder because
they believe he's Japanese.
And then all these other Asian
groups start to get together
and they realize they're
Asian-American.
But they also feel sort of
weirdness because they're
like Civil Rights wasn't
exactly for us.
Right? And so, and so I started
thinking of this interplay
between these two novels.
These two novels are very
much centered in a Chinese,
Chinese immigrant experience.
Chinese-American experience.
But there are a lot of things
that are relatable to
a broader everything.
In all types of marginalized groups.
So, how do you guys see this
sort of effecting readers
of all different spheres?
>> Peter Ho Davies:
That's a great question.
I think with the Vincent Chin case
is sort of the space where I think
about that the most in
the context of the book.
Because, so Vincent gets
killed in a bar room brawl
by some white auto
workers in Detroit in '82.
This is in a period of
deep economic anxiety
where Japanese imports are
being blamed for the decline
of the auto industry in Detroit.
They mistake him for a Japanese,
get into a fight at the club.
Chase him outside.
Hunt him down for about half
an hour and then beat him
to death with a baseball bat.
It's a terrible, terrible case.
And for that, those two
men received fines of $3000
and no prison time at all.
So, it's an enormous injustice.
Thus, speaking of strong
female characters,
Vincent's mother Lilly Chin,
is instrumental in sort
of fighting for justice for her son.
And in doing so, sort of
brings together a coalition
of Asian-American activists
and protestors.
And one of the great ironies, of
course, is that Lilly is Chinese.
Has come from China to the U.S.
in the aftermath of
the second World War.
Fleas China in a sense because
she can't stand to live there
or having seen the Japanese
aggression during World War II.
And then her son is mistaken
for a Japanese and killed.
And then she finds herself
making political common cause
with the Japanese to try
and get justice for him.
So, the circularity for those
things are [inaudible] grizzly.
>> Lisa Ko: Right.
>> Peter Ho Davies:
But in the process
of getting the case reopened, it
has to be pursued as a hate crime
in the Federal Legislation
that has been brought
into the civil rights movement.
And hasn't previously
been applied to Asians.
So, there is this question
of whether there is a kind
of user [inaudible] of rights
that blacks have worked
very hard to achieve.
And fight for themselves.
I think that it leans into
a much larger conversation,
which is a problematic one.
I forget how we rank the struggles
of various immigrant groups
and various ethnic and racial
groups within the U.S. So, I think,
we want to resist, I
certainly want to resist,
the kind of ethnic Olympics here.
Your case is much worse than
my case, and vice versa.
I'm very conscious of
it at the same time.
While trying Chinese work on
the transcontinental railroad,
worked under terrible conditions
and worked for less pay than whites.
They were paid.
Right? So, there are a
significant differences
in the various circumstances of
different groups have suffered
in the history of the United States.
But I also think there is a way
in which, one of the reasons I'm
so interested in stereotype.
It feels as though
one of the issues,
one of the burdens
facing Chinese-Americans
and Asian-Americans more broadly,
is this idea of the model
minority in positive stereotypes.
And in some ways positive
stereotypes, by their very nature,
we might be less inclined to resist.
But in many ways, I actually
feel that's an even greater duty.
We have to resist positive
stereotypes in order
to resist negative
stereotypes, as well.
And if we accept positive
stereotypes, we're acceding
to the logic of stereotype.
That affects not only our own
group but all other groups as well.
So, it does feel important to push
back even on positive stereotypes.
Because they are all narrowing.
>> Lisa Ko: Yes.
And there is a way that the model
minority is always has historically
and continues to be used sort of
as a wedge between white America
and other Americans of color.
So, it's kind of set
up in a way that is
like look Asians have succeeded.
In a way it serves to
delegitimize our own anger
and our own active
racism against Asians.
On the other hand, it also is used
to perpetuate racism against Black
and Latinos, by saying,
well, Asians have succeeded.
Why haven't you?
And it kind of ignores all
these larger, historical
and political facts about why
we've ended up in this place.
I think Vincent Chin is a really
interesting character, too.
Because he's still being used.
This is like over 30, 35 years ago.
And he's still being
used as a catalyst
for Asian-American political anger.
So, I'm always .
. . I don't know if
you read this article
about Asian-American fraternities
that was out by Jay Caspian Kang?
>> Peter Ho Davies: I did.
Yes.
>> Lisa Ko: I was super
fascinated by it.
It just sort of, we're going
off on another tangent.
It's this great in-depth study
about Asian-American frats.
In particular, one hazing
incident that resulted in the death
of a young man in New York City.
But what I didn't know is
that the frats are sort of .
. . having these kind of
Asian-American history 101 lesson
as part of their hazing rituals.
Where they learn about Vincent Chin.
And that sort of what kind
of gets these young men
to feel politically empowered in
a place that they haven't before.
And it's a very ethnocentrus
[spelling] view
of political empowerment.
It lacks a lot of context.
But there's still this
need for, like, you know,
these young men feel the
need to connect to that case.
And then, so, the question is why?
Why? What are we lacking in
terms of our own, I guess,
access to a more complex and
contextual Asian-American identity.
That that case still
feels so meaningful
and fulfills a certain
need for these young men.
>> Peter Ho Davies: Ironically,
one of these that that
article is fascinating.
It was in the New York Times
Magazine about two, three weeks ago?
I mean the case, the hazing death,
has been prosecuted for a while now.
It's an extraordinary story.
The young man in question, I think,
was killed in a hazing ritual
that was called the glass ceiling,
which is very poignant as a detail.
And I would also argue,
I'm not sure about this,
but I have some residual sense
that some part of the violence
of that hazing plays into some
of the questions we
talked about earlier.
The way we see Asian
males and their potency,
their strength, their masculinity.
It almost feels as if this is
an over compensation for them.
The violence of the hazing ritual
>> Lisa Ko: Yes.
It's a very macho, violent.
East-Asian male centric view.
>> Peter Ho Davies:
They become perpetrators
of their own victimhood,
in a certain way.
[inaudible]
>> Mohamed Sheriff: So, before
I open it up for questions.
I have like one more.
So, I'm curious about the
reception of these novels.
Especially now.
How has it been?
And you guys are writing
about very relevant topic.
What's that been for you guys like?
Are you now the representatives
of the .
. .
>> Lisa Ko: Yes.
I am. I speak for all Asians.
>> Mohamed Sheriff: Right.
You speak for all.
[Laughs]
>> Lisa Ko: Across the world.
Apparently.
The largeness.
The largest population.
[Laughs] Yes.
You know it's been
interesting because so much
of the reception has been,
this is super timely.
Because now we have
Trump as our President.
We have this very violently,
anti-immigrant administration.
And the deportation.
The tension in the news in a way
that they might not
have been before.
But what's interesting is that
I did start the novel seven
or eight years ago.
So, it was based on stories that
were happening back in 2008, 2009.
And now, they're sort
of being stepped up.
Right? In the news even more.
It's been an interesting place
to be and an interesting year
to come out with a first novel.
And also about this topic, as well.
>> Peter Ho Davies: It's fascinating
to me the way this actually happened
when I was writing my last
novel, "The Welsh Girl" which was
about German prisoners of
war held in allied hands.
And I began that before 9/11.
But it was an historical novel in
which the present and the treatment
of prisoners of war places like Abu
Ghraib, and Guantanamo get caught
up with the past in a strange way.
And it's certainly been
true with "The Fortunes"
with that Vincent Chin section.
Where we think about the way
economic anxiety and some unbridled
and unfortunate rhetoric associated
with it fuels a hate crime.
And I must admit since I've been
touring with the book, I've more
and more been reading that section.
Because it feels as though
it speaks to the time.
And it feels cathartic, I hope,
for both me and for listeners
who want to hear that section.
One of the ironies,
the bitter ironies,
is that each of the sections of
the book has a brief epigraph.
And the epigraph from that
section was from then,
not quite even candidate Trump,
in about 2012 when he was
first contemplating a run.
And about a year ago, my
editor and I talked about that.
It was a line, I won't quote it
here, because it's fairly offensive.
Not surprisingly.
In regard to the Chinese and it used
an epithet that is an important one
in the context of the
Vincent chin killing.
And about a year ago, my editor
and I, well, more than a year ago,
18 months ago now,
were talking about it.
And she said, this seems
really timely right now
but it might be very
dated very soon.
Of course, all we can say
at this point is, if only.
>> Mohamed Sheriff: Okay.
So, we have about 10
minutes left for questions.
So, if you have a question come up
to these two mics we have over here.
And ask them.
Not all at once.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you all for
doing this panel.
I've just finished
"The Leavers" recently.
And "The Fortunes" is
on my good reads list.
So, in the context that
you've just been talking
about today's political environment.
What would you want Americans to
understand about the experience
of your characters and the
experience of people who risk
so much to immigrate
to this country?
>> Lisa Ko: I mean, I feel like,
as a writer I'm writing
a lot to post questions.
So, ideally, I want my readers
to either identify in some way
with the characters or sort of
question their own thinking.
Or sort of, you know, kind of
raise questions in their mind
about what it means to be American,
what it means to an immigrant.
What kind of questions about
culture and identity mean.
And that's sort of where I'm at
with the book and being a writer.
>> Peter Ho Davies: It
is hard to generalize.
But I think one of the things that
I'm struck by, not just in context
of writing the book, but in my
own life and experience, too.
Is that people who immigrate
here really want to be here.
They value this country and what
it stands for, what it means.
They are patriotic
before they get here,
because of those aspirational
values.
It would be nice to
welcome them in that spirit,
I think, is what I would suggest.
>> Thank you.
>> Actually, I think you
just answered my question.
Thank you.
>> I want to follow up on what you
just said about immigrants wanting
to be here and the values that
they identify with in America.
And kind of go back to what you were
talking with hyphenated identity.
And I was curious like what
those American values, you see,
that immigrants identify with.
And how it's possible to
reconcile them with really holding
onto both sides of hyphen?
>> Lisa Ko: For me, I
feel like I just want
to add more context
regarding immigration.
Right? Like the idea that .
. . I don't want to feel like
so much of the way we talk
about immigration is really in
this kind of strange vacuum.
Like we're not really
looking at how,
why people necessarily want to come.
A lot of it is because the U.S. has
been involved in other countries.
Right? It's like we're here
because you were there.
We've been involved with wars.
We've been involved
with colonization.
So, there's sort of this
reason for migration.
People come out of
because of economic need,
for the most part, I would think.
And because their homelands have
been untenable for many reasons.
So, yes. This is really
answer to your question.
>> Peter Ho Davies:
It's economic need.
It's also economic aspiration.
And so that sounds like people are
coming for your money and your jobs.
But I think they're also coming
for a country that values
and allows for economic aspiration.
So, that's the more
positive way of seeing that.
Something that we all
notionally share, I think.
It's funny.
So, we're on a panel.
We're talking about
what could be described
as immigrant literature
in some ways.
For myself, and I realize that
my own context is very different
from that of many immigrants.
One of the ways I immigrated
before I arrived was
by reading American literature.
So, literature written by
the American cannon is one
of the things that brought me here.
So, literature is an
invitation or was an invitation.
I think it helped me adapt
and made me want to come.
It made me excited
by the possibilities.
And we talk about opportunities and
it sounds like economic opportunity.
But even for me, coming
from Britain,
it feels like cultural opportunity.
It's the opportunity to
reinvent oneself, I think.
I could not have been a writer
if I'd stayed in Britain.
I'm pretty confident about that.
So, those are some of
those aspirational things.
>> Thank you.
>> Mohamed Sheriff: Come up.
Come up.
>> Thank you all for
talking about this
and for writing about
your experiences.
I wanted to ask a question
regarding sort of the then
and now of the immigration.
Some people come here, immigration,
looking for, as you say,
more prosperity, leaving
an economic situation.
Some people come here because
they don't want to come here.
They're refugees from
wars and other issues.
And your book has a lot
to do with the railroad
and before the Communist
state, basically.
So, there's a whole different
psyche of the people who wanted
to come here post cultural
revolution.
And I think that your book
probably is more about that group.
So, what about that?
What about the before and
after immigrants that came
to the United States,
why they're here
and how their identity
is attached to that?
>> Peter Ho Davies: I
mean, there's no denying
that there are different
historical circumstances of arrival.
And certainly, when the first
Chinese came for the gold rush
and even to work on
the transcontinental,
they saw themselves as
sojournic [spelling] community.
They would come.
They would make their money.
They would take it home.
And that was one of the
sources of resentment, I think.
One of the things held against
them by other new arrivals
in U.S. who came to settle.
So, that was one of the gaps between
them, I think, in various ways.
And yet, I think, one of the things
I thought about a lot in the context
of writing "The Fortunes"
and sort of looking at that,
100 to 150-year history of the
Chinese in America was to think
about how even later arrivals,
even though they arrived
for different reasons,
in flight from war,
for flight from Communist
regime in many ways.
Their reception is shaped by
those who come before them.
Right? The stereotypes that
are attached to men who arrived
with cues attached to Chinese
who come in the 50s and 60s.
So, there is still the way,
there is a kind of hangover.
So, if the reasons, the rationale,
may be different for the immigrant.
Their perception by the space
in which they enter is shaped
by those who come before them.
There is almost a failure
to understand those
distinctions, I think, in some ways.
Of why it's such a great question.
>> Lisa Ko: And that's an
interesting point, too.
Because it's like who gets
to be seen as a settler.
And as an adventurer or a pioneer?
And who gets to be seen as
the foreigner, the invader?
Right? I think that's
something that has been timely
across all of U.S. history.
And there is a way
that, in particular,
for many Asian, Asian-Americans.
There's that stereotype of
being perpetually foreign.
Even if you're fourth generation.
And that says a lot about, I
think, how we're seen in the U.S.
>> And what about within
the community?
Like, I'm Armenian and I'm
actually writing a book
about the Armenian
immigrant experience.
There is a pre-Soviet
thing going on.
And a post-Soviet thing going on.
So, there's the people who were
here first that the real Armenians.
Who were here first?
Now the post is like .
. . so for the same thing for
every ethnic group, really.
So, there's an established
immigrant community.
And then a new wave comes in.
>> Lisa Ko: An access to language,
fluency, citizenship, money,
you know, all that
stuff comes in to play.
>> So, how is that in your book,
because yours is more modern?
Like, your story is more modern?
How did you approach that part?
Did you approach that part of it
or did you want to incorporate?
>> Before you answer that.
So, we don't have time for you
to answer this last question.
Sorry.
>> Lisa Ko: My family, my
characters are undocumented,
working class, very
recent immigrants.
So, because of that and their
own access to citizenship status
and fluency, and money,
they are kind of located
within a certain community within
Chinese people in New York.
>> Mohamed Sheriff: All right guys.
Thank you so much for coming out.
I hope you learned something.
>> Lisa Ko: Thank you.
>> Mohamed Sheriff: Thank you
guys for giving us your time.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.